live local now good morning with john  langler at the anchor desk hector me  here with the traffic clicker sherry's  off today so nathan tonnenbaum in the 8  news now weather center a look across  the strip obviously a legion stadium but  there is a little bit of haze that has  settled over the valley but the other  thing you're going to notice  it is cooler outside still muggy 76  degrees but down 10 from 24 hours ago  humidity in the neighborhood of 40  percent but no wind to speak of so that  going to be hanging out there for a  while especially with the wind blowing  it in while it's moving storms out to  the east so let's take you hour by hour  we're going to be in the upper 70s at 8  upper 80s at noon only the mid 90s for  the high this afternoon again that haze  and smoke is going to be an issue for  you throughout the day